Traduttore: Evelyn Montes
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Pensiamo al cervello
di un bambino di un anno.
Sapete quante nuove connessioni
si formano, ogni secondo,
tra i suoi neuroni?
Circa 700.
In un'intera giornata
fanno più di 60 milioni
di nuove connessioni.
E ciascuna di queste nuove connessioni
rappresenta una nuova sfumatura,
un nuovo concetto
che il bambino ha imparato nel mondo
tramite la sua esperienza.
I bambini sono i campioni
dell'apprendimento,
ed è a loro che guardano le tecniche
più moderne di intelligenza artificiale.
A distanza di circa 50, 60 anni,
da quando Alan Turing
lo aveva teorizzato per la prima volta,
si sta facendo
finalmente strada il concetto
che se vogliamo creare dei sistemi
autonomi davvero intelligenti,
non dobbiamo cercare di infondere loro
tutta la nostra conoscenza,
bensì dobbiamo renderli
capaci di apprendere
nella maniera più efficente
e autonoma possibile.
La prima volta che ho avuto a che fare
con l'intelligenza artificiale
avevo circa 15 anni,
e nel mio tempo libero,
per quanto questo
possa suonare un po' nerd,
avevo creato un piccolo programma,
un piccolo giochino,
in cui un Pierino virtuale
doveva fuggire da un lupo,
pena [l'] essere divorato.
La cosa particolare è che non avevo
programmato Pierino per scappare dal lupo,
bensì gli avevo dato soltanto
la possibilità di muoversi
all'interno di una piccola mappa,
gli avevo dato la possibilità
di vedere il lupo,
ma soprattutto, lo avevo dotato
della capacità di apprendere
dall'esperienza
tramite un semplice algoritmo
di intelligenza artificiale.
E così, dopo averlo lanciato
in questo mondo, acceso il programma,
ho visto Pierino prima imparare
che stare nei pressi del lupo
non era una grande idea,
e poi addirittura imparare a scappare
il più velocemente possibile
non appena lo vedesse in lontananza.
Ed è così che mi sono innamorato
dell'intelligenza artificiale.
E ancora oggi,
che progettare sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale è il mio lavoro,
ed è il focus dell'azienda che ho fondato,
ancora oggi vedere sistemi
di intelligenza artificiale
imparare autonomamente
a prendere decisioni
solo tramite l'esperienza
sui dati che gli mettiamo a disposizione
è per me qualcosa di veramente magico.
Ora sono passati quasi 20 anni
da quel momento,
da quel Pierino virtuale,
e oggi la tecnologia
è tutta un'altra cosa.
Di fatto,
l'intelligenza artificiale oggi è tra noi.
Ad esempio è in grado di guidare
in maniera più sicura di noi umani,
è in grado di batterci
in giochi di strategia
che fino a qualche anno fa sembravano
di dominio solamente umano, assolutamente.
È in grado di riconoscerci,
noi e i nostri amici,
quando carichiamo foto su Facebook.
Ma soprattutto, ci aiuta
in tantissimi ambiti già oggi,
dalla finanza fino alla medicina.
La frontiera tecnologica
è rappresentata dal Deep Learning,
cioè apprendimento profondo.
Il Deep Learning si fonda
sulla costruzione di cervelli virtuali
dotati di migliaia di neuroni
e milioni di connessioni.
E impara tramite la riorganizzazione
di queste connessioni
dopo ogni prova ed errore che effettua
sui dati che gli mettiamo a disposizione
durante l'allenamento.
Quindi, durante la fase di allenamento,
prova a prendere decisioni,
ci prende, sbaglia,
e nel frattempo riorganizza le connessioni
all'interno del suo cervello virtuale,
e così facendo impara.
Proprio come un bambino, quindi.
Il problema è che, proprio come
un bambino che diventa adulto,
anche per questi sistemi
di intelligenza artificiale
più conoscenza significa
meno flessibilità nell'apprendimento.
Quindi, più conoscenza,
E questo è un problema.
Ed è un problema
che si esemplifica in particolare
in un'altra tecnica avanzata
di intelligenza artificiale
chiamata Reinforcement Learning,
cioè apprendimento per rinforzo.
Il Reinforcement Learning
funziona tramite ricompense virtuali
e punizioni virtuali
che vengono date al sistema a seconda
dell'esito di ogni sua decisione.
Quindi, ad esempio,
un sistema di Reinforcement Learning
che sta imparando a giocare a scacchi
verrà ricompensato
ogni qualvolta fa una mossa
che lo mette in una posizione
di vantaggio rispetto all'avversario,
mentre viene punito virtualmente
quando fa una mossa non opportuna.
Così facendo, mano a mano,
giocando tante partite,
il sistema impara.
Il problema è che quello che si verifica
è che, dopo un po',
dopo che ha imparato un po',
il sistema tende,
di fronte a situazioni simili,
a scegliere sempre la prima strada
che gli aveva portato
una ricompensa in passato.
Quindi, di fronte a situazioni simili,
va sul sicuro. Ha paura di sbagliare.
E questo rappresenta un enorme problema,
perché non è detto che la prima strada
che ci ha portato una ricompensa
sia anche la strada
che ci conduce al successo maggiore.
Di conseguenza
ci si è inventati un escamotage.
E l'escamotage consiste,
di quando in quando,
non sempre, però di quando in quando,
durante l'allenamento del sistema,
di impedirgli totalmente
di provare paura di sbagliare.
Quindi, ogni tanto, il sistema
non ha paura di sbagliare,
e si sente libero
di sperimentare nuove strade,
prendere nuove decisioni.
Così facendo,
la maggior parte delle volte
fallisce miseramente, ovviamente.
Però, ogni tanto, scoprirà
una nuova strada, una nuova strategia,
un po' creativa, un po' diversa,
che lo porta alla fine
a un risultato nettamente migliore.
Ed è proprio tramite queste tecniche,
questo genere di tecniche,
che hanno in comune il fatto
di mirare a consentire
ai sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
di sbagliare di più, non di meno,
durante la fase di addestramento,
durante la fase della loro formazione,
che oggi l'intelligenza artificiale
ha raggiunto il successo che conosciamo.
E non è ironico tutto questo?
Non è ironico che proprio noi umani
che critichiamo gli errori degli altri,
che critichiamo aspramente
chi ci prova e sbaglia,
siamo anche quelli
che stanno regalando il valore dell'errore
all'intelligenza artificiale?
Stiamo regalando il valore dell'errore
all'intelligenza artificiale,
quando potremmo imparare così tanto
proprio da questa.
Ad esempio, nel Deep Learning
cerchiamo in tutti i modi
di impedire al sistema
di memorizzare i dati che gli mettiamo
a disposizione durante l'allenamento,
perché se così facesse,
perderebbe totalmente la flessibilità
di adattarsi a situazioni nuove.
E allora perché noi umani
obblighiamo ad esempio i nostri bambini
a impiegare tantissimo tempo
ad imparare a memoria date e dati
che inevitabilmente dimenticheranno
alla prima verifica?
Perché il sistema educativo, spesso,
si fonda di più, e premia di più
la memorizzazione
rispetto alla comprensione?
E ancora, nel Reinforcement Learning
abbiamo visto che la paura di sbagliare
viene vista come un problema,
per cui si cerca ogni tanto
di consentire, durante la formazione,
di non avere paura di sbagliare
affinchè il sistema possa scoprire strade
che lo portano poi a successi più grandi.
E allora perché, tra noi,
quando qualcuno cambia strada
durante la propria formazione,
o addirittura durante
la sua carriera lavorativa,
viene visto come uno scapestrato totale?
Perché chi cambia idea,
in seguito a esperienze di vita,
in seguito a riflessioni,
è prima visto come inconsistente
che saggio?
E infine,
abbiamo visto, e sappiamo,
che l'intelligenza artificiale
impara qualcosa
tutte le volte che sbaglia.
E allora perché continuiamo
a vedere l'errore come una sconfitta,
quando in realtà
è soltanto il primo passo
sulla strada del cambiamento
e del successo?
Grazie.
(Applausi)